el trabajo agrícola cooperativo frente
al cambio climático es la solución que
han encontrado varias comunidades de
guatemala frente a los problemas que les
ha traído la sequía este proyecto
implementado por la organización de
naciones unidas para la alimentación
cuenta con cerca de 5 mil 900 campesinos
en rabinal a unos 150 kilómetros al
norte de la capital vive alberto cortez
uno de los campesinos que explica en qué
consiste la iniciativa promover las
buenas prácticas agrícolas como los
fines de la ecología familiar que es uno
de los
que debería practicar todo familia en
las comunidades del corredor seco y
otras comunidades el proyecto sin
embargo no se centra sólo en la
agricultura trabajamos varios enfoques
mucho lo que es
un tema juventud el tema género grupo de
mujeres y llevar este como un método
educativo según la fao el 30 por ciento
de las personas participantes son
mujeres especialmente vulnerables en un
país que se sitúa como el segundo más
vulnerable al cambio climático en
américa latina' israel el chico es otro
de los cooperativistas y está convencido
de las bondades del cooperativismo la
cooperativa pues para mí es una
herramienta de cómo uno puede salir
adelante cómo puede desarrollar las
cosas de una forma muy efectiva muy y
muy transparente en guatemala el 59% de
la población vive bajo el umbral de la
pobreza iniciativas como ésta podrían
suponer un reactivo a la precaria
situación de muchas personas en el país